and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode 161 today
we're gonna talk about our addictions
Ryan all of them our addiction of stuff
and shopping our addiction to drugs and
alcohol our addiction to outrage in
drama as a society and our addiction to
success in achievement Ryan in today's
world it seems were overwhelmed by our
addictions yeah man well well I think I
think it yeah it's probably best starts
by by talking about what is what is an
addiction and we'll also differentiate
it from a few things so according to the
National Institute of Health addiction
is the condition of being addicted to a
particular substance thing or activity
despite harmful consequences and it is
often characterized by an inability to
stop I had some smart out a lucky person
on Twitter yesterday say how can you
help me stop my addiction to oxygen and
I can't stop and okay that's not what an
addiction is because oxygen itself has
very beneficial properties to it an
alternative yeah it's interesting
because like I before I even like before
weeds decided to do this podcast I would
have agreed with him I would have been
like oh yeah I mean you have to have
oxygen or you die right there are a lot
of things we have to have or or we
benefit from
well I benefit from having a bed I'm not
addicted to having the bed because there
are no harmful consequences of having
the bed right there's a piece of lint
right here on your microphone oh we have
to remove is that it I'm so so I got it
I have OCD you totally got it and so
let's talk real quick about the
difference between addiction and
obsession there's a lot of overlap like
if you have a a Venn diagram of
addiction and obsession there's going to
be this huge sort of overlaps okay I
have this definition here broke my
computer out so that we could talk about
it this is from
Side Malibu which I believe is a
addiction treatment center and the
article here which we put a link to in
the show notes it's called what's the
difference between addiction and
obsession I'm just gonna read the first
two paragraphs when the average person
thinks about addiction most people think
about drugs alcohol tobacco and maybe
shopping or gambling when a person is
addicted to drugs or alcohol they are
chemically dependent on the drug and you
could say the same thing about well a
caffeine is a drug obviously now it's
weird we say drugs and alcohol but
alcohol is just a drug we could we can
say drugs well yeah because it's it's a
drugs tobacco and alcohol and those are
all tobacco and alcohol or drugs right
and and those are all addictive drugs
there are some drugs however that are
not addictive LSD is a non or psilocybin
is a non-addictive drug it doesn't have
the same addictive properties now you
can become psychologically addicted to
virtually anything yeah I could be
addicted to its styrofoam or it's a very
clean microphones yes that's more about
obsession which will dive into here in a
second right people who suffer from
addiction many times also have other
co-occurring disorders such as
obsessive-compulsive disorder there's a
strong correlation between addiction and
obsessions an obsession is a ritualistic
routine that becomes part of your normal
life medically speaking it is a
persistent occupation of a feeling or
idea which can be accompanied by anxiety
and I think it's one of the reasons I'm
often my levels of anxiety tend to be
higher than yours hmm it has a lot to do
we both have addictive personalities
which we're going to touch on in this
episode for sure they manifest
differently mine manifests often through
through obsession which is this
ritualistic routine or ritualistic
thinking obsessions can include
excessive hand washing or repetitive
counting I I don't have obsession
obsessive hand-washing although I know
yesterday we were on a flight we were
flying back from Chicago and that
guy who was sitting next to me totally
like it was coughing and stuff and I'm
like all right I'm gonna ask him if
he'll switch seats with you mm-hm and we
end up working out but like I definitely
went to the bathroom and wash my hands
but that to me was just reasonable I
mean yes preventative right I mean dude
I get on an airplane and I got those
little sanitizing wipes right like I
wipe everything down cuz you know I just
I read this article a year or so ago
where they were talking about how it was
like confessions of a flight attendant
or something and one of the confessions
was is those trays that come down and
everything the screens those never get
cleaned and it's amazing sometimes that
you take one of those wipes and you wipe
everything down and it's like mmm black
almost yeah it's crazy well so yeah it's
being preventive all right the end so
there's a difference between being
preventative and and being excessively
preventative and that's one obsession
comes the counting thing that it
mentions here that's definitely
something I have and I don't always
notice like I can tell you right now
there are 44 steps between my car the
the stairs it within the parking garage
and the bottom floor yeah like it's just
something that that I don't realize I'm
doing it I'm just counting as I go in 1
2 3 4 5 and and I find myself counting
different things from time to time
unintentionally an addiction is slightly
different rather than a focus on ritual
an addiction is about a mental escape
from reality obsessive and addictive
behavior behavior can be commingled
rather easily by recognizing what enough
what is obsessive and what is addictive
however you can go back to each
individual root and address the
underlying problem the rest of this
article talks about therapy can be very
beneficial there are different types of
therapy like CBT therapy cognitive
behavioral therapy to address obsessive
compulsive disorder and also to address
addictions now we're going to talk about
addictions more broadly today let me
hand my computer over here to jordan no
more and let's see i think i think with
with the questions we're gonna deal with
today we'll talk about
alcohol and substance abuse but we'll
also talk about the broader addictions
before we get into that though like I
think one of the reasons that minimalism
was appealing to both of us is it was
helping us in a way curb our addictions
or really get these superfluous things
out of the way
or maybe it's maybe it's a matter of
like getting rid of the addictions and
bringing in obsessions maybe well there
are different types of obsessions right
healthy obsessions like I get obsessed
with writing and and and for me I think
love is one half passion one half half
obsession but it has to be the sort of
healthy obsession and that equation
works when you flip it around as well
passion is one-half love one-half
healthy obsession so the it's to say
healthy obsession it seems a bit
redundant because obsession by
definition is something that is healthy
it's as healthful elite not necessarily
it's ritualistic in a way so obsession
itself is is bipartisan in this case
right it can be healthy just like it's
like same food mm-hmm there's some
terrible food out there that's going to
kill us and give us but cancer yeah
there are other foods that are gonna
nourish our bodies make us energetic
make us feel like our best selves and
prevent bug cancer but cats but see but
so you want to get but when an obsession
an obsession turns unhealthy that's when
it becomes an addiction it usually that
is the case yeah because an obsession
returns ritualistic or or just become we
become dependent on alcoholism which
I've had a lot of experience with
personally not I'm not an alcoholic
well actually I probably am an alcoholic
I've never had a drink in my life
because both of my parents were
alcoholics and I saw the the extreme day
and they were extreme alcoholics and not
even functioning alcoholics and it
ruined their lives and and I saw that
happen and and for me I saw the that
ritual turned in it devolved into wasn't
even a ritual anymore it was just an
everyday all waking hours occurrence
yeah until they were both dead well
let's talk about like
so you're obsessed with writing yeah but
let's say that you were writing this
morning and you were getting so obsessed
with it that you were like you know what
I'm not gonna leave this room until this
is done right you called Jordan and Sean
and I and you're like sorry guys cancel
on the podcast cancel everything today
I've got to finish what I'm writing
right and then like you don't leave your
room for a week until you finally so is
that this is at that point is it an
addiction I think so yeah no I I think
because if we go back to that initial
definition from the NIH addiction is the
condition of being addicted to a
particular substance thing or activity
right it would be an activity in this
case despite harmful consequences right
and so when you start neglecting
everything else now now for us we were
we were actually neglecting the most
important things in our lives that our
health our relationships our creativity
so I was neglecting writing for a long
time now my drug of choice was
consumerism also sort of status and
achievement and success accolades it's a
weird thing to like one
you know trophies or whatever one of the
equivalent of trophies our and our
consumer culture the trophies are often
the trinkets or the objects that we're
able to acquire with the money which is
the barometer of of success often in our
culture and now there's this new
barometer as well and in the world of
social media it's it's social media
clout that becomes something that we
become addicted to it's like wow and the
weird thing is you know you and I will
sometimes joke with each other about
this like oh now I had now we have you
know 300 followers on X platform I guess
I'm allowed to be happy now like this is
the key to happiness of course it's not
though because then you see the person
with half a million or a million or ten
million or 50 million followers and you
feel inadequate so we get addicted to
the comparison we get addicted to the
success you know the perceived its
success so could social media be a
healthy obsession yes I think so because
it's a vehicle right and I think I think
a lot of the times you and I we
have a very deliberate way of how were
you social me in fact we hire Jessica so
that she could help us be deliberate
with how we are using social media we
use it as a platform to do two things
one is to broadcast a message that we
find will add to the greater good so
we're we're trying to add value to other
people's lives when an add to the
greater good but also we want to
interact with people as well and so we
use social media to interact in a
positive way not to not to interact with
the trolls or or to fuel to feed the
trolls fuel the fire of outrage because
that can be the unhealthy side of it we
can get addicted to the oh well I'm
gonna get you back or whatever there's
some people who do it really well I
think crystal Lee he has a really fun
time feeding the trolls and then
subsequently killing them killing the
trolls you know with his with his words
but he's he that's his art form in a way
hmm
and and and so yes it can be it can be
addictive or it could be a healthy
obsession now for you and I you for me
consumerism was the the drug of choice
for my my parents their drug of choice
was was alcohol yeah my drug of choice
was drugs drugs of choice
yes and those became not just physically
addictive because they certainly were I
remember you going through withdrawals
but also psychologically addictive like
I need this in order to get through the
day or to get through this relationship
get through this job get through this
interaction get through this day of
meetings and it became this sort of
psychological addiction as well yeah and
and that's the the dangerous side of of
substances that are addictive is they're
both chemically addictive yeah and
psychologically addictive yeah that's
dangerous man yeah so we've got some
questions a day about all of those
topics let's go ahead and dive in here
our first question today is from Lois in
Queens New York
my brother is alcoholic and he's going
through a tough time and it's forcing my
family so much stress because he's
extremely ignorant and he does not want
to listen to us when we try to offer
it drives me to a point where I think I
can't do any more
I'm currently I am 20 years old and he
is 31 he never got his life together and
I don't believe that that should be my
responsibility because he just so angry
at all times and I'm the type erson it
looks her life good night I truly
cherish it I would just love to hear
some feedback for some advice because
I'm good luck
now Ryan he said something fascinating
there toward the end of his question he
said it's not my responsibility and and
to a great extent I agree with that you
just like well I can't force you to be a
Utah Jazz basketball fan right I mean
maybe if I really like communicated how
important it was to me that you became a
Utah Jazz basketball yeah yeah you'd be
willing to play okay I'll sit down and
watch the games with you and at the same
thing if you're like John I really need
you to sit down and watch the Cincinnati
Bengals games with me this every Sunday
I tell you that I mean I know you
wouldn't but I'd be like well I really
love Ryan care about him I'll find a way
to get in to this with him although it's
not my responsibility to to be a
Cincinnati Bengals fan in order to to
make our relationship flourish now I
bring up that hyperbolic percent even
hyperbolic it's a parodic example of
responsibility and I say that to say
this because I've gone through a lot of
alcoholism and my family man I'm sorry
to hear Louis that you have a brother
who is struggling with alcohol addiction
I know how difficult it can be my mom
quit drinking dozens if not hundreds of
times and you know she had a stack of
AAA coins that leave the one day sober
coins this is back in the 80s and and in
90s the one week so were the one month
so in like she had quite a few like one
month sober coins cuz once you go back
to day zero then all of a sudden now
it's one month sober now I don't know
that that's especially helpful I think
if you're an alcoholic
and you've gone a year without drinking
and you mess up you know you don't go
back to zero you now have one loss out
of 366 losses like our wins that's
that's pretty amazing to me yeah and and
so it's almost like this weird defeatist
mindset where if if I am if I have
succeeded succeeded succeeded one loss I
think of the you know the best football
team were the Patriots were they're the
best now the realm of the Rams yeah Rams
in the Chiefs what's the Rams score
right or a record right now what is this
it's the week nine I think they're eight
and one because they're eight and one so
so when they if they won the first eight
games and they lost the the ninth game
you wouldn't be like well it starts all
back at zero they're a terrible team
right no you acknowledge like wow look
at all that success that they have had
and it's a way to reframe the success
and you know what Louis your brother is
probably struggling a lot because a lot
of people are looking at him as a total
failure I know you're looking at him as
a failure right now you in fact you use
what would he say Ryan said that he's
extremely ignorant yeah I mean what how
do you use that kind of vocabulary with
someone that you love
well it's it comes from a place of love
actually you know Lewis here loves his
brother yeah and he knows what his
brother needs to do to live a meaningful
life and when someone we love continues
to make poor decisions then we tend to
look at them and because it makes us
angry because hey we can't do anything
about it and worse like you're watching
someone harm themselves so that feeling
comes out in anger and it comes out with
calling people ignorant and calling them
idiots and calling them stupid that is
that is a that is a very natural I feel
like that is very natural response
because when I walk past the bums on the
street the homeless folks who were like
you know literally like just on the
sidewalk no sleeping bag no let me just
passed out yeah sprawl it out and I
don't look at them and think you
ignorant bastard yeah I just looking at
I'm like oh man
so yeah I'm so sorry you're going
through that but went on someone we love
it creates this this anger I know so
we're talking I've experienced that with
my mom I've experienced that with my dad
whether it's drugs or alcohol or whether
it's you know religion whatever it may
be but I you know I have these
conversations in my head where I'm like
talking to my dad and I'm like you're
such an idiot
and then I have to catch myself I'm like
now he's not an idiot he's just lost and
so so Louis maybe that's where maybe
that's where Louis needs to start is is
by maybe reframing how he's looking at
his brother's situation regardless so I
agree with you man it's not his
responsibility it's not anyone's
responsibility to cure him of his
addiction because his brother will never
get help unless he wants it yeah and I
noticed yeah I know they should through
experience man like so many people in my
life including myself um you know I I
did not start to pull out of my my crazy
horrible addictions until I actually
wanted to get help until I made the
decision where I was like yes I need to
get help and then then it is Louis's
response what make is not a
responsibility because you know I guess
we're not entitled or nothing is truly
demanded of us and you know as long as
we're not hurting other people but but
maybe that's where it becomes a
responsibility when Louis's brother
calls him up and says I'm ready to get
sober and I need your help
yeah so you know Louis supports your
brother as much as you can like that's
the only thing you can do don't enable
him don't make his bad actions be okay
and that's sometimes what we conflate
sometimes we think that well by me in a
but the only way for me to support him
is to enable him I know I thought that
off of my mom and that doesn't that that
just leads to a more vicious cycle right
where they depend on you for their
substance abuse yeah I mean I've had
friends family who you know they've
called me up hey man can I borrow a
hundred bucks and then you know give him
a hundred bucks and then I find out that
they go and just spend it all on drugs
and that's why they needed a hundred
bucks was for drugs it wasn't for what
they told me they needed it for and when
I found that out the next time they
asked for a hundred bucks I'm like hey
you know what I'm not gonna give you any
money I'll be here to talk with you I'll
be here too if you need me to buy you
groceries or something like I'm here to
I'll go to the store
with you but I'm not going to give you
cash I'm sorry yeah and and and I think
that's the difference between enabling
and support you can still support
someone without without necessarily
enabling them I like what you're saying
about I use this word but but compassion
right that that's that's really what
you're talking about here is
understanding what they're going through
when you talked about the homeless
person on the street you don't go up to
them and say oh you're ignorant you're
stupid what are you doing you're lazy
you understand like oh that poor person
and it's the same thing with your
brother the problem the more difficult
thing here is you have to continue to
confront it over and over and over and
eventually there will be a point where
you have to distance yourself at times
it doesn't mean that the distance is
permanent but sometimes the best way to
support someone is from a distance
letting them realize that they're
ruining their own lives well it's it's
funny man because like my my family one
side of my family they they have this
rule they're like we don't call the cops
on family that's not what we do and this
enables my family to treat each other
like garbage sometimes steal from each
other yes that is not my rule and oh
that's good you get to make up your own
rules yeah absolutely
and and I'm not you know here's to call
the cops on his brother someone I'm
saying it all but what I'm saying is is
that yes you do get to make your own
rules no matter how your family looks at
it because the bluest might also be
experiencing pressure from his parents
or from maybe other siblings hey why
don't you help your brother more I know
that I used to get it thrown on me hey
Ryan you need to come here and talk to
your brother and help your brother more
yeah and and and and and I did at one
point went and talked to one of my
brothers and you know he was going
through an addiction problem himself and
you know talking to him I'm like you
don't even want to stop do you he's like
no I don't and I'm like then why am I
here dude yeah you can't help someone
who doesn't want your help right and and
because then you're just forcing your
own objectives your own goals your own
life your own beliefs your own two
is your own intentions on that other
person the best way to get someone to
change is not to change them it's to
show them why change is necessary
important enjoyable desirable if they
can understand that then they're more
likely to change if they actually want
to change yeah and sometimes creating
that that distance creating that
separation like that's that is one
reason for them to change well last week
I recommended that movie beautiful boy
during our added value segment yeah and
it's a movie about a father who's
dealing with his drug-addicted son he's
addicted to meth and heroin and well
pretty much all drugs and so at some
point he just he falls down deep when he
turns 18 he is just like he goes off the
deep end of adventure there's a point
spoiler alert in the movie where the
dads like the the son calls him up and
he's like dad I just really need I need
your help
and the dad goes I'm sorry son I can't
help you anymore because there was what
he realized every time he came back to
him asking for help he was actually
asking for enabling right he was asking
for the he was asking for more money he
was asking for basically I want you to
support my drug habit right he wasn't
asking for real help right and there's a
difference there are times when
someone's asking for real help or
they're asking for you to help them hurt
themselves and you know I would I would
say too late
let's say this has not happened so this
is just this is just an example but
let's say I had a friend who came to me
and they were really addicted and I told
them like hey I'm not gonna give me any
more cash but I will you know I'll help
you out if you need help buying
groceries or something right so then
they come to me they're like yeah I
really need help with buying groceries
so I go and buy them groceries just to
find out that they had you know 50 bucks
for groceries but they decided to spend
it on drugs rather than for groceries
like I wouldn't I wouldn't feel bad
about helping them at that you know but
at one time but like I would learn from
that mistake what I'm trying to what I'm
trying what I'm trying to say is is that
when you're dealing with someone in your
life who you don't want to enable but
you do want to help them I you might
have to lean a little bit towards the
enabling side just a little bit just to
at least like offer that bit of help
because some sometimes the help can be
enabling yeah um but you know if I
helped a friend bribed by groceries and
then come to find out later like I was
actually enabling them well then I can
go back to the okay I need groceries
again I can be like no we went through
this last time when I bought you
groceries but so I guess I'm just trying
to help people find the balance between
giving someone the cold shoulder yeah
and and and then you know actually going
out of their way to help someone you
might actually be enabling them a little
bit but lean towards I'm just saying
lean towards that enabling side rather
than the turning a cold shoulder does
that make ya don't lean towards enabling
lean lean towards support and just
making short support and maybe a crosses
over to that enabling side for a second
but don't don't stay over on that
enabling side yeah and you have to be
really careful about that and all
with with your brother if you're dealing
with anyone who has an addiction you may
not be able to help and sometimes the
best thing to do is not let go of that
person but let go of your expectation of
how you want that relationship that
other person's life to be I'll tell you
the worst thing that anyone can do in
this type of situation that loses in is
continuously cast judgment on the person
who is suffering yeah because that
person do Lewis your brother knows that
he's extremely ignorant like he looks in
the mirror every day probably in his
like I know what I'm doing to my body
he's actually not egg but I can't help
it that's the thing he's not in there he
knows what's going well in earnest sense
that he's continuing to do self harm to
himself like and knowing that he's doing
self harm to him so those he's behaving
badly if this if this you know coffee
was like boiling hot and I put my finger
and then I was like oh yeah and then I'm
like I'm gonna do that I get ow
right that's not ignorant you know that
it's high yeah but it's in tune into an
extent that I know better but I can but
yet I continue to do it right it's it's
a it's a bad behavior that you continue
yeah yeah and I think that the other
thing the note here it's but you you
started a conversation with this Ryan
and I think it's really important you
don't wanna meet their anger with more
anger because it's you're right it's a
natural inclination like they're angry
at you especially in the moment cuz they
want that money so they can buy drugs
and why won't you just give them money
and shut the hell up and get out of my
way so I can go do this I can go buy my
you know beer or wine or whatever it is
and you want to lash out you want to say
no after that we're gonna in a and it
just escalates the situation yeah if
they come to you with anger and know
that it's not because they're actually
angry at you it's because what's the
substance talking and and it is a
reflection of how they feel inside it
has nothing to do with who you are you
can be the best way to be supportive in
that moment is to walk away and say hey
look I see you're really angry right now
this isn't a time for us to talk about
this I'm going to have to walk away yeah
Louis are
minimalism live a meaningful life which
I don't have a copy on the table of
right now Shawn do your job of your
earliest convenience I am actually if we
can get shot in the sent you a copy of
it there's an entire chapter about
relationships and the thing that really
stands out to me with this is our
relationships with other people are
often there they're camouflaged there's
there's this external facade that is
created by our addictions whether it's
the stuff to substance to whenever we're
addicted to and it's pushing past that
and seeing what's really important about
the relationship how do I be caring
supporting loving how does that align
with the values in my life and so this
book minimalism live a meaningful life
it's the first book we ever wrote and
it's about the five different
foundational values in our lives health
relationships creativity or passion and
growth and contribution I think you'll
get some value from that book Luis will
either send you the audiobook version if
you like our podcast you'll love the
audio book or if you want the book book
or the e-book podcast Shawn will reach
out to you and get you one of those SF
alright if we love to hear what you all
have to say so if you have a comment or
a tip about addiction including advice
for any of our questions today leave us
a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm why are our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode and stay tuned to the end of
this episode for this week's listener
comments and tips Ryan what time is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning round
Ryan and I each do our best to answer
every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our quotes in one place
minimal maxims dot-com well write our
first lightning round question is from
wild thoughts and crazy dreams
how do you break the addiction of
wanting to compete with others because
you believe you deserve what they have
hmm
look I've got a I've got a short but
rather practical answer and then we
could talk about it here my my pithy
answer is some cultures consider
competition to be a mental illness and
well I wouldn't go that far and say all
competition is a mental illness I'd like
to delineate different types of
competition they're just like obsession
there is healthy competition like if you
and I were to go play well we play ping
pong all the time yes and it's a healthy
competition and and there's nothing like
hateful there's nothing that's addictive
about it like we did we're both
aggressively average at ping pong and we
think we're way better than we actually
oh yeah yeah and and and you're probably
slightly better than me but sometimes I
will beat you in fact maybe 51% of the
time I'll beat you because I think I
might try 1% harder or something but the
point is like it is a friendly
competition the pernicious competition
is thinking that you're in a competition
when you actually aren't right when all
of a sudden it's like oh they have a
Lamborghini and I just have our
mercedes-benz I am clearly losing yeah
this competition they don't even know
they're competing with you you're
competing against some imaginary figure
in your head and the reason that I I use
this pithy answer if some cultures
consider competition to be a mental
illness I learned this when we were
living in Montana right I would
occasionally do the sauna at the YMCA
but with folks from the Blackfoot Indian
tribe there and one of the folks there
talked to me about like it's weird how
Westerners think of like if it's a
win-lose zero-sum game right whereas in
our tribe we think of it as a mental
illness like if there's a person who's
being competitive then there's something
wrong with them mentally and we need to
like find a way to help them understand
that if you win I win
and if you're losing I'm losing and and
that's what's going on with the previous
question from Lewis is ladies family is
feeling that actual loss of late
well he's losing so we're losing and and
when you think about it that way you
realize like oh the people around me if
they're winning then I'm also winning
yeah man and how good does that feel and
then you work as a team because you want
to help each other win and well I think
I'm gonna save this next bit for our
next question Ryan what's your pithy
answer cool I'd say there's no need to
compete with the Joneses if you're
living up to your personal standards if
you still feel incomplete raise your
standards I mean when I look at when I
feel like when I look at my life before
and when I felt like I had to judge my
life compared to someone else's life it
was because I wasn't doing what I knew I
needed to do in my life to live a
meaningful life now wild thoughts and
crazy dreams sounds to me like they're
not worried about competing as much as
they're worried about status and that
that is always going to be an issue if
you're worried about your status
compared to someone else's status that
is a losing game because even if you
become the president of the United
States like you're still there's still
another status that you're gonna be
chasing right and by the way if you
become the President of the United
States seemingly no matter who you are
is not a political answer here break any
president ever half the country just
likes you
yeah yeah I mean if you become earth
czar I mean it's you still you still
will always be searching for that next
that next status as soon as I become our
czar I will outlaw onion a lot of people
are gonna dislike me for that as soon as
you as soon as you wild thoughts and
crazy dreams as soon as you start to
live up to your own standards and you
start to feel more complete you will you
will honestly by default
stop looking for that status I mean this
isn't like a you know magic bullet
answer meaning that you're never gonna
want the Porsche or the Lamborghini
however when your life feels complete
when you start to feel more complete and
you do that by living up to your values
and beliefs but by living up to your
standards
you you are looking less externally for
things to to make you happy
so so so the so that's in order to get
over the the addiction of status you
have to you have to live up to your own
standards that that is how you that to
me like that is how I stopped looking at
my status compared to other people's I
think an additional pithy answer there
is worry more about impressing yourself
than others yeah absolutely absolutely
alright our next question is from
Melissa how can we stop an addiction to
success well Melissa my opinion sir to
this one is simple we fail when our
definition of success is excess and so I
think we need to redefine what success
means if we're if we're worried about
impressing other people if we're worried
about a particular dollar amount if
we're worried about a clout or a number
on social media if that's your
definition of success you're gonna get
there you're gonna make it as a horizon
and realize the destination was never
there in the first place yeah and so I
think what you need to do is figure out
what does success mean to you does it
mean growth and contribution doesn't
mean creativity does it mean thriving
relationships how do you define success
and how do you redefine success so that
empowers you to live a meaningful life
not live someone else's template of life
yeah my answer would be ask yourself why
you want to be successful if it has to
do with how others see you you'll never
truly be successful you know what dude
if I could redo that pithy answer I
would say exactly what you just said on
the previous one don't worry about
impressing anyone but yourself like
that's it's so true well PS Ryan we have
three more questions oh wow
holy moly hobby baker asks what are some
good ways to fight the urge to buy
something just because it's new or looks
good and emma says they say some people
have addictive personalities well I know
two of them do yeah do you think that's
true
huh and is it something they should work
to change in themselves let's talk about
that but also Garrett says how does one
overcome food addiction which was a huge
one for me you know a lot more about 80
pounds more than our way now Garrett
says how do I overcome food addiction
namely binge eating due to stress so the
stress is his trigger here and if you'd
like to hear our answers to those
questions you can listen to this week's
post script episode over at the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively to our patreon supporters so
if you want to become a supporter of our
show and keep this podcast 100%
advertisement free it head on over to
the minimalists comm slash support we
also do a bunch of other stuff for our
patreon our wonderful wonderful patreon
supporters in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes the minimalist
private podcast feed includes our ask
the minimalist anything episodes
unreleased recordings of our live events
you know we've done 15 live events in
the last year on patreon and we recorded
those live events and put them out
exclusively on patreon
you also get unreleased recordings of
our what you get all the back catalogue
of the past private episodes and once
you become a supporter you'll receive a
personal link to our private podcast
feed so that plays in your normal
podcast player so you don't have to open
up an internet browser and listen to our
podcast you can listen to it right there
in your podcast player you can find all
the details and all the good stuff over
at the minimalists comm slash support
thank you so much if you are a patreon
supporter we are really grateful and
here is a snippet from this week's
PostScript episode
a habit itself is not inherently good my
mom had a habit a smoking habit right
and that is a habit and you have these
certain triggers like with smoking it's
like oh well a meal triggers smoke a
waking up first thing in the morning
triggers the first cigarette having a
cup of coffee is a trigger for a
cigarette
going to the bar is a trigger for a
cigarette now you can do one or two
things you can replace your triggers
mm-hmm and and and/or avoid the old
triggers and put new triggers in place
or you can take that same trigger and
say this triggers something different
now you reset the habit all right Ryan
it's time for our added value portion of
the show this is where we talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently so there are two albums
that came out this year from the
producer Apollo Brown hmm and it's
getting near the end of the year so I'm
going to have to compile my favorite
albums of the year and I know at least
one of these probably both of these will
make it on my top 10 or top 12 list
whatever I end up doing at the end of
the year but it reminds me of sort of
like blending 90s hip-hop like the
production of 90's hip hop with with
today's music so it feels both retro and
contemporary at the same time it's like
the best of both worlds the best of what
has happened and the best of what is
happening so Paula Brown is producer and
what he does is he like partners up with
an emcee as he did Joell Ortiz and that
album is phenomenal real listen to in
the car the other day I think it was all
of us we were going around filming some
stuff for like living room conversations
in this 30-day minimalism game video we
were doing and I was playing you were
like what is this I'm downloading it
right now well it was the Joell Ortiz
and Apollo Brown album and I was good
yeah it's called Monalisa and then he
did one with Ghostface from wu-tang as
well just it's just a Paula Brown and
Ghostface from wu-tang and it is I mean
man I felt like I was back in like 1994
or something what a great album and
there's a there's this line on the intro
from the
Joell Ortiz album he said I remember
when making music was like taking a
brush and creating art that would live
on for years and it speaks to like how
music these days is often especially in
hip-hop is more ephemeral so this mean
the other day I was like when ugly
people made music it was so much better
it's like now you can't be famous unless
you're like super attractive right yeah
you have to be Justin Bieber right or
cardi B you're late yeah easy or
something right yeah and so I what I
found here with both of these albums
they felt timeless I mean I don't truly
believe in anything being timeless
because you know go back to the Middle
Ages and no one was wearing blue jeans
although we call blue jeans a sort of
timeless fashion but it feels timeless
in terms of our lives both of these
albums do so we'll put a link to both of
those in the show notes Ryan what about
you man I just watched oh I'm gonna make
make two recommendations I just watched
the The Iceman documentary that Vice did
for wim HOF yeah it's incredible mint
and like I was telling you this before
the podcast wim HOF is kind of like this
modern-day miracle worker uh-huh but the
thing is is that the miracles that he
helps people perform is all
scientifically based and that's what I
love about it yeah it is
I mean there are you know certainly
things that happen in people's lives and
like oh that was a miracle and I'm not
trying to discredit people who think
that you know those miracles have
happened in their life but I'm saying
like what when what wim HOF does is
scientifically proven well talk about
who wim HOF is people don't know who he
is
so the Iceman is a gentleman who when he
was 17 years old he kind of went on this
this journey trying to find a connection
with himself uh-huh it started with
looking into various religions different
meditation techniques and then in a
certain point he was just kind of drawn
to cold water and like like ice-cold
frigid cold water I forget exactly where
he's from but I know thanks for the
other one yeah it is another one so it's
cold up there it gets cold up there yeah
and what he realized
that when he got into the cold water
there's this primal instinct that kicks
in where he's able to he was able to
kind of feel something deeper within
himself and he did this for years and
years and years and he started to
realize like his immune system was
getting better he wasn't getting sick he
was he eventually got to the point dude
I don't even saying this I don't even
believe it but it's true
the dude cause it's true because it's
backed up by Stanford research right
yeah but what I'm about to say I don't
even think it like it to me saying it
doesn't even sound true okay yeah but
but the the dude climbed Mount Everest
in his shorts yes it would have done it
in bare feet but the problem is that his
feet kept slipping so he had to put on
kind of like what I have zero shoes like
the zero shoes that I have with spikes
on the underneath of it is functionally
bare feet right exactly but it was
functionally bare feet the dude climbed
Mount Everest in his shorts man
like if that ain't a miracle I don't
know what is but what's beautiful is
that he was is able to show anyone
anyone to be able to hold their breath
longer to be able to go into cold water
but what's really impressive about wim
HOF is it's not just about dealing with
the cold this is about dealing with
depression it's about dealing with
anxiety it's about dealing with anger
it's about dealing with sadness it's
about dealing with health issues there
are so many things that that his method
helps with it's not just being able to
get into an ice bath and up until I saw
this documentary I thought it was all
about just being out in the cold it is
so much more than just being able to
deal with the cold now are you gonna be
able to climb Mount Everest in your
shorts you know I would never try to
replicate that personally like I don't
have that that driving me to like prove
something that I had that I have to do
that right but certainly anyone out
there can watch this documentary and
just get an idea of what his methods are
and then maybe dive a little bit deeper
after you watch the documentary but you
certainly can you can increase your
health just through breathing it's crazy
so the second thing I want to recommend
is we actually have a living room
conversation yeah with wim HOF we're
gonna ready to record it right now yeah
he's gonna show up in like about an hour
hour and a half
and he's going to do a livingroom
conversation with us and he's gonna show
us and our audience how to how to
breathe and to calm ourselves so like a
calming breathing technique so I've
called the wim HOF method yeah I would
highly recommend anyone listening to
this if you deal with stress anxiety
sickness just give it a shot I mean it's
it's I know it's it sounds woowoo II
when I talk about even though I have
seen the evidence in you know seeing the
science explained it still seems like
really whoo-whoo II um but but so I'm
just imagining for someone who hasn't
dug into it how they probably think I
sound crazy right now but just dig into
it and like you will see how it is
scientifically proven that like this
dude can basically help your body
perform things that science never
thought was possible right he's
stretching the boundaries of science and
and and and the beautiful thing is it is
being backed up he is he they've done
some experiments at Stanford with him
where they have injected people I think
with the flu or the common cold yeah and
he has shown them how to basically
manipulate their own and control their
immune systems there was a fight off to
fight off the flu or fight off the cold
yeah there was um the I think it was the
one you're talking about where they had
they had 12 subjects mm-hmm 12 people
did the breathing methods
12 people did not they were both given
maybe it was the flu I think it's what
your flu virus all 12 people that it did
the breathing method but it didn't get
it right all 12 people who did not do
the breathing breathing method got sick
might be in that control group it's just
yeah it's it's truly remarkable and yeah
it just it really helps come it just
helps you to feel more confident in
general yeah I can't wait you can do
with your body I can't wait to meet him
and we'll put a link to the living room
conversation we're going to do with him
about that breathing exercise so if you
want to check out the breathing exercise
it'll be really quick I mean you can
learn it just in a few minutes and you
will walk away feeling I mean I've done
the wim HOF wim HOF method before and
you feel elated and you feel kind of
high and I'd like to see if there is a
way for me to it's a natural high yeah
and you can avoid the sort of addiction
to its substances and may
we replace it with something meaningful
helpful useful yeah dude I do it every
single time when I do the cold plunge of
vota I'm doing his breathing exercise um
it's funny though on the documentary
that the dude with Vice he's like
talking about how he's breathing he's
like he starts to see these white spots
and then he looks at the camera he's
like wait I don't know if I'm like it's
before it's like kind of early into the
documentary he's like I don't know if
I'm depriving my brain of oxygen and
that's why that's happening or what but
basically what it is is you are building
up oxygen in your system sure for your
body to hold on to yeah all right let's
move on real quick to right here right
now so we talked about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalists if you
want to comment on this episode you can
do so you can do so over at youtube.com
slash the minimalist we've got a whole
bunch of other good things going on on
our YouTube channel right now quickie
episodes of the minimalist podcast we're
doing one of those a week right now
we're also doing living room
conversations one of those a week
including the one with wim HOF but Ryan
and I we give out some simple advice
about simple living and we're doing a
house tour both of our houses really
soon and if you want all of our podcast
show notes you always hear us talk to
podcast Sean and he writes down very
faithfully all of the the podcast show
notes to share with you if you want
those in your inbox you can sign up for
email lists over at the minimalists comm
just enter your email address there at
the top you'll also get on Sundays we
have a simple Sundays at our website so
you get new emails every Sunday with new
writings or videos or anything else that
we're putting out including the new
essay that we have out there right now
it's called how to go clothes shopping
mm-hmm that's over at the minimalists
calm right now Ryan what else we got man
you know I just want to really encourage
people to read more and get informed I
think by listening to this podcast by
reading our books people are getting
informed with our lives but you know
broaden your perspective read read
things you hate it just read
perspectives you hate just to at least
understand where people are coming from
right you know it's taking things for
face value I think is it is really
hurting the world it's not just our
society it's not just America it's
making a divisive and I like the what
you're talking about reading both sides
of the aisle or whatever not even both
sides all sides because
are often more than more than two sides
it steal man's your own arguments as
well makes them stronger makes you
better understand your own position or
maybe it just changes your mind yeah
all right so read more and get informed
oh and here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners - Ryan this
is a suggestion for anyone who would
like to give a gift with difference and
he's based in London all be visiting
London during the festive period and
they've just opened up a store in SoHo
called choose love where consumers can
buy gifts for refugees and these gifts
aren't things that are extravagant and
they're basic items such as blankets
clothing accommodation even and support
networks it's not support network access
and the gifts range from about 5 pounds
to 600 pounds you can buy the whole
store and for anyone who's not able to
go in physically there's actually an
online store as well and so the place is
called choose love and it's a gift store
for Refugees hello my name is Amy and
I'm calling from Richmond Massachusetts
this comment is for Josh Ryan and all
those who may have experienced trauma in
their lives I've recently discovered a
therapeutic approach called EMDR which
stands for eye movement desensitization
and reprocessing this approach centers
specifically around trauma and is a
break from traditional behavioral or a
talk therapy Josh you had mentioned a
few times during podcast that you were
still trying to figure out how to deal
with certain traumas that occurred in
your life I'm in a similar place and I
have found great value in being able to
process events in my past in a new way
with the MDR and I wanted to share this
with you Ryan and your listeners in
hopes that you may find value in it as
well
hey minimalist is Kari from Casey I just
wanted to share what we do for Christmas
I was listening to the Black Friday
episode and just thought that what my
family does is pretty pretty great as
far as simplicity during the holidays I
have five year old son
who
has everything he needs so for Christmas
we let him pick out two toys that he
will get and those will be his his big
gift he usually told us are on
Thanksgiving you know what he wants and
then forget about it by Christmas so
it's a big surprise and then we usually
donate it around you know Valentine's
Day to you know March ish if it's still
in a pretty good condition but for our
family we like you guys will give gifts
of charity or just give them cash but
for the moms the grandparents we always
make like a candle from like Shutterfly
and you can take a picture usually we do
like a family photo and make that you
can paste that to the candle instead of
like the label or the company name that
you buy the candle from and that way
they can burn their candle and have the
photo that will hopefully bring them
some some joy and then when they're done
with the candle they can just throw it
away and they don't have to worry about
using a photo up in their house or
having extra photos lying around that
way they can have it for this season and
then next year they know that they're
gonna have another one all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm and if y'all leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
minimus